I mean alpha have been captured by the
enemy
[Music]
serious trauma to painted agent down
acquaint Bravo has been taken by the
enemy point alpha with captured by your
team
Charlie is not held by your team by your
squad I mean alpha have been captured by
the enemy
boo stick now actor
Charlie is now held by your team Bravo
is now held by your team point alpha is
an enemy hands
boost about to come on
right
most online
so deactivate
it's assistants
the enemy can team up the mercy rule is
about to be invoked right Alfred is now
held by your team
vital signs critical agent action I sent
a specialization supply drop your way
down a specialization supply drop happen
it arranged for you
Point Charlie has been captured by the
enemy point Bravo has been captured by
the enemy's point alfred is now held by
your team
[Music]
[Applause]
my drop has expired point alpha is an
enemy hands
immediate medical assistance needed
agent down Charlie's be held by your
squad Bravo is now held by your team
teammate down point rather is being held
by your squad
[Music]
serious drama detective agent action
five-minute breath
agent killed agent killed teammate eat
assistance
boost about to come online post online
the boost is being taken by the enemy
and the enemy has acquired
the enemy it's just deep instead of the
way to victory when Charlie doesn't have
any hands
quaint Bravo is being held by your squad
point Bravo have been captured by the
enemy alpha is being held by your squad
immediate medical assistance needed
agent down
it's now held by your team when charlie
is now held by your team
I'm sending you a specialization Supply
Drop
immediate medical assistance needed
agent in capacity that's one for the
friendlies the enemy just pulled out
[Music]
you